[Music]
jack
this thing between us i can't deny it
anymore i don't know jimmy i must have
you
okay yes to all of this
anyone want to get this train back on
track
you're a tiger
[Applause]
oh god i'm so stressed and my hair is
falling out ah look at that it just
falls out
uniforms promote conformity okay you're
gonna turn these kids into mindless
zombies like a cult i do not see that
happening
we're really getting somewhere now
faculty and students we are officially
in a tornado warning papadurbs will keep
you safe
we're all dead no we're dead no do not
live in fear bye
now i have something to say to you and i
want you to listen very carefully can
you please just confirm that you didn't
kill anyone i have a go bag boss
whatever you need no questions asked
where's my son jack it's not like him to
be late i imagine whoa
are you mr mr griffin i suppose i am dad
my god look how big you are been this
size for over 20 years holy sh
ready to begin
[Music]
we have decided to make you a fully
fledged member of the team you're gonna
make me a vampire
today is our first day as leaders of the
vampiric council
is there not a throne for all of us
[Laughter]
do you have to step on it come on
in the name of jesus christ
i don't have to talk to modern women 700
years ago i just say hey you get on the
back of john john was my horse
that was called dating
hi werewolves
[Music]
we get it you're a vampire killer with
the stakes and the reflexes and all that
great job okay
objection this is your fourth objection
in the last minute overrule objection
what about objection
how do you work this day you fancy a
ride let's fire it up
just get in i'm fine just a little fire
for now i am letting nandor think that
we are sharing power i will make her my
number two
but there can only be one supreme leader
we haven't decided
what we do in the shadows do you ever
wonder that there is more to this life
than just mindless killing and bloodlust
yeah you do of course not good night
thursday september 2nd on fx next day fx
on hulu
i am charlie dimiglio you might know me
from tech talk can you ever really
imagine a hundred million people
you can get famous really fast on tick
tock i don't know how charlie blew up
it's crazy my sister dixie she is my
best friend you get on my nerves on
purpose though like i breathe sometimes
and that really sets her off oh
god
we had a very happy life in connecticut
and this is a risk
it's important to have family and
friends that will stick by you to go
through a public breakup was terrible it
was right person wrong time you love him
they're normal kids that doesn't change
with a following
starting music with a huge audience is
very scary
this is the discovery process we're
figuring out what you're good at
i just feel held to a very high standard
do you look through hate comments of
yourself what we're trying to do is have
some fun and make sure social media
doesn't destroy our lives
there's always going to be people that
hate on you for no reason
making sure you're happy first is the
biggest thing
dixie very protective over me she's been
going through a lot you're shaking you
can help her
the millions of people watching your
every move that's like constant hair
sometimes i feel like it's my fault my
family's out here it's definitely a lot
of pressure on me
this is a look at your 2021. is there
room for dance and to be a kid
i want to try and keep that as normal as
it was
i'm going to earn everything i do
i have no idea how this is going to work
out knowing what i know about our family
we're going to get through it together
to tell a true story of us
we're trying to get you down
i've never snuck out that is something
that i've always wanted to do we won't
look we'll leave all the doors open
[Music]
locked up for a hundred hours
trapped about to be killed
and having lost a best friend
it feels like a hundred years have gone
by
checkmate
lisbon to professor
hi lisbon
the storm water tank has been discovered
it's possible this is the last time i'll
speak to all of you
we got them
captain
i'm bringing the military in they'll
come out victorious or come out dead
[Music]
say goodbye to her
no father
no plan
no
hope against the ropes
but we're not gonna end up in the morgue
this is our last dance fatty make it a
good one
right now
with me you'll find authentic liberation
and if we ever have to pay a price for
it
[Music]
some people have control over their
emotions
i don't
i was trying to find any way to escape
i want the story out there like what
happened go frame by frame
there you see jenner now shows
tremendous speed
[Applause]
i spent my entire life hiding
i didn't want people to know me and know
who i was
daddy bought his son his own hockey team
i'm the president of the danbray trashes
and i'm 17 years old he had the backing
of organized crime
she is the professional boxer he is the
trainer he's controlling everything
inside that ring
you're on my territory
i'm about to play the greatest player of
all time and then all of a sudden the
whole weight of the stress
just came flooding in
boom
it turned out there was something bigger
going on underneath
a fight broke out between the pacer team
and the fans in the stands people were
trying to hurt me and others it was a
full-scale riot
he said if you leave i'll kill you
listen do what you have to do 9-1-1 what
is your emergency her name is christy
martin
we were to scum of the earth to the
purists of the hockey world
we were driving these people crazy
you're making a mockery of the lead
this was the largest
investigation i've ever been a part of
i'm never talking about this [ __ ] again
i might get beaten but you cannot kill
me a man accused of using mob influence
he's playing one of the biggest matches
of his career
i was olympic champion greatest athlete
in the world
but i was still the same old person with
all the same old issues
[Music]
as you no doubt heard
you get to work in the west wing as of
this morning
you're going to be working right beside
the people who run the world
please
be professional
there's a woman i'm very close to
in the midst of an affair
but the president of the united states
how do i know it's true
[Music]
hello
you will lose her as a friend
i've made my peace with that are you
sure you have enough evidence
my calls with monica
holy [ __ ]
it all has to come out
the press will destroy her
you don't know the half of it my wife
went into a hotel room with bill clinton
it is online mr president do you know a
woman named monica lewinsky that's me
that's my face
this isn't about justice
then what is it about
impeachment
william jefferson clinton
do you solemnly swear
that you will tell the truth
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
god
i do
i did not
have
sexual relations with that woman
[Music]
yo play that beat against huh
i thought he get you open like six packs
this is where you should be putting your
work into
lock the streets
just like this
i grew up on the crime side
this work we do
the new york times side it's all for
family and we just trying to make music
yo
you listening to beats
you ain't listening to the whispers out
in the streets
it must be nice to have dreams
but they ain't real
this house is real that food on your
plate the money is real
your weight ain't the only way huh
the pond behaves like a pond because it
believes it's upon
i'm sick of this
what
this life
a king
rules because he commands power
this is our home for god's sake got to
be stronger that way
[Music]
we may be from separate hoods but we
gotta stick together
gonna make you big
[Applause]
out of the way you two keep everyone
back i'm here to help you this looks
like attention pneumothorax i need to
borrow this sorry
oh he saved it
who is this kid my daughter the doctor
earlier today a man's life was saved by
a local teen doctor dr khame aloha we'll
be taking care of you aloha mr lin is
this some kind of practical joke you
know who she's like remember doogie
houser that show from the 90s she's like
a real life dookie houser that's why we
call her doogie i never made the
connection girl why did you think we
called her tooting
being a 16 year old doctor is kind of
like having a superpower doctor may i
have a word with you i think we got a
little something right mom gross well
are you hungry
i love you doctor it's impossible to
work with lahella and be her mom she
shuts me out i was hoping we could take
the car i'm afraid not a second ago you
were my boss you don't get to control my
entire life
i held a man's heart in my hand
yesterday i worked so hard and get
nothing my little doctor sister has so
much to learn i think she just needs a
room to make mistakes like all teenagers
i'm afraid she's missing out nothing's
gonna stop me nothing's gonna stop me
now tomorrow night will be my first date
with walter hey
hi
have fun you two
i kissed walter
i'm a doctor now and it's not fair that
i get all that pressure but none of the
fun
i just feel so ready for everything
you are extraordinary
you're just saying that because you're
my mom
i'm saying it because it's true
[Music]
the science supports my hypothesis
walter likes me
science science science can you guys get
out of here it's my xbox time only on
disney plus
let's just start with what you were
doing before the event this evening i
was driving a motorcycle cop you were
bribing a police officer indeed not for
the first time and up until recently you
consulted for the lapd
and you also claimed that you're the
devil was the devil god now well nearly
and how old would you say you are again
one time works very differently in hell
so
he's just sensitive about his age i mean
even i don't know the real number
it's time for you to assume your place
on father's throne what's the rush
becoming god is a big job maybe he
doesn't want to go in half cup i should
definitely be full cocked
i need your help i thought i wasn't your
therapist anymore and look at what's
happened
the world has no god clearly i belong on
his couch lucifer
what is that
that is my friend
excuse me
something i can help you with wanna help
me destroy lucifer morningstar
the laws of nature are breaking down
and the apocalypse is nice
there's only one thing we can do
vacation in colombia beautiful beaches
mountains of illicit drugs
[Music]
none of us know exactly
how it's going to end
dude he was like that when i found him
[Music]
never bring a knife to a devil fight
[Music]
i'm ready i hope so because i make quite
the entrance
we still have one mystery left to solve
the murder of lucifer morningstar
[Music]
i certainly did not see this coming
[Music]
mr president you're not fine
come on guys
[Music]
but it wouldn't be nothing
nothing
[Music]
[Music]
madam president power plants will start
to shut down which which city all of
them
somewhere is the answer to how this all
happened
and how we fix it
[Music]
who are you
jorik
you're reproductively interesting wow
okay
uh
people are gonna have to pick sides
they are hungry
[Music]
angry
terrified
we will rebuild together
[Music]
when it comes to symbols of the past
there are still a lot of people who
ascribe extra natural powers to symbols
sign of the cross number 13. luck
symbols bad luck symbols at what point
though do benign symbols become
malignant
you're one of the sharpest students i've
ever had
raw answer i could only take you so far
peter i knew this was going to be
life-threatening i would have just gone
to the library
professor
i was expecting peter he asked me to let
you know about the urgent situation
hello you will solve the great mystery
[Music]
he's been
taken i don't know exactly what's going
on
i teach symbology i expect you'll find
the sun the lantern the key the hand of
the mysteries
did this person say what he wants he
wants me to locate an ancient portal
buried within the capital
and unlock it how's your latin not as
good as my hair babe
do you happen to put that key back you
mean this no no one told me to put it
back
you didn't think it was gonna be that
easy did you
there's a purpose to everything he's
done world wants to be deceived
so let it be deceived this is only the
beginning
the game is changing
my job is to ensure the stability of uva
alex i need you to come back you are the
only thing that can save us
i don't think i've ever said that before
i'm not going to get edged out alex levy
i feel like i'm bringing in my big
sister to clean up my mess man you can
underplan this any better stepping away
when you did
i was broken doug
yeah
ratings have been down this network
needs to clean up its act five try and
get ahead of this corona virus
four someone should cover it well
bradley can do it three don't forget
this is your show and we're back two i
know i come with a history that not all
of you love one nine months ago you
opened a door and you need to walk
through it now
a bombshell from journalist maggie
brenner's upcoming expose on the
behind-the-scenes troubles at uba's the
morning show
there is a pattern of behavior around
here that disadvantages the people of
color we need to get our facts straight
we need to decide what the truth is did
you hear what you just said
maggie i would like to see the book you
don't like me you've never liked me
that's not true
which part
onward and upward
you're a dynamo out there i don't think
they're using you in the right way i
don't trust her she seems perfectly
nice oh can't you bugs me
[Applause]
i'm your boss i'm gonna make sure it
works out oh you're my boss i thought
you were my friend i'm on your side the
network doesn't think you have the it
factor we're looking to showcase some
other talent you know what the problem
with racism is you don't fix it by
pretending to want to fix it
what i want is to change things because
the jury's still out if you were
successful
happy days are here again
[Music]
in case you forgot i'm the whistleblower
i am going to get everything i want
you're just so caught up in ruling over
your rotten little fiefdom
the rest of the world they've moved to
the cloud and it is gorgeous up there
[Music]
this is a battle for the soul of the
universe
[Music]
[Music]
choose more down choose more there
choose more dale oh hi miss haddon you
can call me hope
i'm jackson marchesse head boy
ex-dolphin star but you might recognize
me from romeo and juliet within which i
played romeo i don't actually
i'm the new head mistress of mordill
taking over from mr groff to get the
school back on track and together
we'll build a brighter future at
moordale
with a new uniform
new student body and a new attitude
mordell is the perfect place to grow
into the fine adults we are destined to
be destiny
you'll also get to hang out with us
which is obviously iconic
extracurricular activities are your time
to shine here at mordecai i'm sorry
it's cute mordell gives us the skills we
need so we can get the careers that we
want
allowing our creativity to thrive
it's fine like the chlamydia outbreak
did last year
choose mordale
choose
more dial
more there baby come on choose more dale
please
so this can end reopening our doors to
once again become a pillar of excellence
see you there
it's only natural to wonder what if
sorry this is yours
i'm joe i mean me and what is it that
you want to do i'm going to be the next
billy joel
guy can dream right what if i asked out
that girl i just met
[Applause]
[Music]
it's freaking juilliard you're like my
superhero for getting in come to the
beach i need to tell you something
what if i married my best friend
sorry we had three code blues and the
hospital was short staffed can you
believe we made them at least we did one
thing right
joey come on we gotta go what if i
followed in my father's footsteps
officer joe kimbrough was a true hero
what if you could see the roads you
didn't take nothing's ever
[Music]
you good literally living the dream i
just want to be ordinary joe
my biggest dream is to be a dad what if
we're not meant to have kids
i know it was my idea to work nights
more money for christopher's health care
but i just want my best friend back
there you are
you don't want to be an old dad joe
tick-tock that's all i'm saying frank
just help me out here have we met before
we bumped into each other at graduation
[Music]
[Applause]
so you ever get that feeling
that one choice could change your whole
life
[Music]
we were never as alive
as we were that year
pretending like our lives were a 90s
musical
don't you want that feeling back
what people just burst out in the song
you are black and gay both groups
notorious for spontaneous singing
[Music]
dear white people counting down till the
day i graduate
the varsity show is a week away that
corny sketch comedy thing isn't that
like snl written by amateurs and yet
somehow still better written that's dope
90s musical but black baby
our culture
i will spontaneously combust into
glitter
oh
i just wish there was something on my
schedule worth waking up for if you have
to add something
go ahead and add something that's fun
[Applause]
black ideas black music
does anyone else our age even listen to
it it should be all right
or is it mostly just 30 year olds who
tend to write characters in our age
group
[Music]
is this the legacy we want showtime at
winchester menstrual c black af is
protesting the show and anyone involved
we have a chance to tell our story the
next generation is out to cancer
consider it a badge of honor if you do
this right the varsity show can launch
you to the stratosphere
got that obama look in his eyes
it feels
[Music]
if we don't cancel each other out
there ain't [ __ ] anyone can do to stop
us
[Music]
[Music]
don't be scared i'm not scared hey
stop it
man she's tough
i know
i dig it
it's weird to grow up in a time when
your mom and dad have to give you the
police talk or when a presidential
election creates a racial divide but it
was 1968
[Music]
the year i turned 12
the age of locker rooms
bullies
and
girls my mom's making me wear pantyhose
yuck
yeah
yuck
[Music]
12 was the age i was gonna figure out
what my bag was
i'd never be as popular as my sister as
smart as my mom or as bad as my dad
be cool
what kind of music professor would i be
if my daughter didn't go to college bad
enough my son doesn't have rhythm hey
yet
my son doesn't have rhythm yet
[Music]
front of the box watch the fastball back
of the box watch the curve
if you got a problem with the way i
coach cesa can you stick to the duvet
knees and i stick to the one two three
that doesn't even make sense it's just
wrong
some people didn't feel like we needed
to mix black people with white people
i didn't understand all that what's
happening chad how's it going quentin
like jesus you're trying too hard
but i decided what my bag would be
the great uniter
think about how possibly to have our
teams played each other why would you
want to play with a bunch of white boys
why does that matter how do you know if
you don't try isn't that what you're
always telling me
what would you do with it i feel
different everywhere i go
worm with cory and brad
we all feel different
i finally get to feel the same as
everybody else
it's the little things that you remember
all your life
your first hit
your first kiss
the first time your dad lets you know
that he sees you
well i still hadn't had the other two
but boy did that third one feel good
[Music]
there are mysterious things in this
world that they're keeping an eye on
i think there's something he needs to
show me
we appear to be dead how do you already
be remembered was there another way or
not
wake up you're in danger piffle powerful
bindi what the hell happened
there is something weird going on people
comfortable they are
how does this crap keep happening what
you're experiencing is the eternal
flagellation
[Music]
we're all the way through the looking
glass now
[Music]
when i was a child at the edge of the
galaxy
i heard stories about a man who could
forecast the future
but the story remained dark to me until
many years later
until it became my story
[Music]
until it became the only story
you're familiar with my work psycho
history every mathematician has read
your theory it's not a theory
it's the future of mankind expressed in
numbers
and the empire won't like the future i
predict
history is littered with charlatans and
false messiahs
we should kill them
we can murder the man but what about the
movement brother
martyrs tend to have a long half-life
his math was right the empire is dying
wars will be endless
thousand worlds reduced to cinders
change is frightening
especially to those in power
but we can soften the fall
so what's the plan
many years from now
if humanity is to climb from the ashes
the coming generations will need the
knowledge to build upon a foundation
we must preserve only the most essential
pieces of civilization
deciding what is remembered
what is forgotten
we are now staring down a barrel
of a crisis
this is the plan
i'm not turning around now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we tend to dislike
mysteries
we feel uncomfortable not knowing
[Music]
the more that we know
the less we bend
the more brittle we become
the easier to break
[Music]
but i wasn't a hecticon
[Music]
wasn't it
[Music]
it's okay to just look at the world and
say why why why i don't
understand
why
[Music]
who are you
you know who i
[Music]
they said i am for six minutes
i was dead and then i wasn't
do you remember any of it
it's like fragments of my life
randomly thrown together
it's like i'm supposed to take care of
something
as you all know tom true has left for
personal reasons we're very fortunate to
have billy mcbride taking his place
i don't trust mcbride litigating one of
the biggest pharmaceutical lawsuits in
history i'm very aware of his reputation
well his reputation is he wins cases
[Music]
your clients flooded this country of
billions of pills that killed over 200
000 people for profit
these guys were ordering employees to
triple even quadruple pill shipments
their greed is pathological
you apparently don't know that you're
[ __ ] with the wrong guy billy
i've always admired your ability to
remain calm
in the face of an impending shitstorm
i think i'm being played
[Music]
there's always someone
watching
they're killing people and i want
[ __ ] justice what are you gonna do
this is the beginning of the end i'm in
the mood to stick my fist up your ass
and pull out billions
you get it
[Music]
when we was growing up we wanted to be
like young boys incorporated
all them dudes had money women clothes
and flock whips
but more than anything
they had respect
that's my card oh it ain't full it's
about bosses and one day i'm gonna have
one just like it meech you coming to
what
letting my brother in the car with me
that day
took us on a journey beyond our wildest
imaginations
man
everybody in the game knows the risks
getting arrested robbed or even killed
as part of it
the rules always been the same ain't no
other way and the competition thickening
you telling that lamar silas is back in
town
the good lord thanks you for that
benevolent orphan brother
so you're a policeman now
cause them men need weapons to do their
job
what kind of job you got you need a gun
it's not like that then what's it like
demetrius
a mother's love can only go so far
nobody gained nobody's [ __ ] in this
country too they didn't give us our
freedom order right to vote we had to
fight for that [ __ ] it's the same way as
us fighting for independence in this
game man so what you saying
we're gonna be kings team kings of the
[ __ ]
you gonna end up in jail or dead i
promise you one thing
i will do better protecting this family
you